[Music]
when we look at the world's skills one
of the biggest sources of it is us
failing to do the right thing when it's
the harder thing to do
giving in to temptation giving in to
impulse giving in to emotional sort of
immediacy and the part of the brain
that's most central to whether or not
that happens is the frontal cortex most
recently evolved part of the brain we've
got more of it proportionally or more
complexly than any other primate species
out there it's the part of the brain
that does impulse control long-term
planning emotional regulation does all
the stuff where it's the frontal cortex
that whispers in your ear saying you
really really want to do that right now
I might not do that you're a regretted
it seems like a great idea frontal
cortex about that okay so when we look
at our moments of life where there's
that enormous temptation to do the
impulsive thing and what's going to
determine whether the world will be
freed of impulsive Horrors if only we
can all get stronger frontal cortices
trained and childhood to be able to hold
out where you can have one marshmallow
right now but if you wait you can get to
later and training from early age so
that your frontal cortex has the most
like fabulous aerobic metabolism ever it
could just make you and what the study
suggests is at all sorts of junctures of
doing the harder thing yeah having our
really robust studly frontal cortex may
do you a lot of good there but when you
do sort of the truly difficult thing
when you see people who are the ones who
run into the burning building to save
the child and their leap into the river
to when everybody else is standing there
like headless chickens when you look at
those people they're not doing it
because they've got the most amazing
frontal cortexes on earth that could
reason through the long-term
consequences of oh what if nobody in
society came to the aid of strangers
what they do is they do it automatically
you at you ask anybody who does one of
these heroic acts what were you thinking
when you jump to
the river and the answer is always the
same I wasn't thinking before I knew it
I had jumped in when we do our most
amazingly like wondrous altruistic acts
it's not because we've got the most
incredible frontal cortexes on earth I
could like one reason us it's because
it's out of the realm of the frontal
cortex and it's out of the realm of
temptation and limbic stuff we do the
harder thing in a case like that because
for us it's not the harder thing it's
become automatic and that's where you
see it you see the best success with
temptation when it isn't tempting when
it's automatic when we've distracted
ourselves all of that frontal like work
your way through the right decision gets
you only so far
fabulous study addressing this this was
worked by a guy at Harvard named Josh
Greene who put people in a study in a
brain scanner of some task where if they
got it right they get a reward afterward
and so there's an incentive to get it
right and this wonderful manipulative
setup where at various point people were
under the impression that there was a
glitch in the system and the computer
wasn't registering their answers so all
they had to do is think what their
answer was and then tell you afterward
when they heard that the correct answer
had they had the right answer or not in
other words they could cheat and what
you would see is it was a random task so
most of the time people were having
about a 50/50 percent success rate and
along comes the opportunities to cheat
and if people's accuracy suddenly jumps
up at that point
aha that's how you detect a cheat or
someone who's long at that point so the
question becomes what's going on in the
brains of people who achieve is it those
opportunities and what you saw was as
soon as that active came up their
frontal cortex is activated like mad
they're wrestling with Satan they're
wondering if they should do it or not
they're wondering if they should have
done it the last time when they were
honest they're wondering if they're ever
good they're wrestling all of that okay
so that makes sense then you look at the
people who cheating opportunity or
otherwise never cheat so what's going on
of them and we've got the two models
there one of we
power is because they've got frontal
cortexes that can chest like be be stoic
and Calvinist and gumption out the wazoo
there or is it the state of grace they
don't cheat because you don't cheat and
the prediction there is if it's all
about willpower as soon as the
opportunity to cheat comes up their
frontal cortices are going to go through
the roof in terms of activity if it's a
matter of grace whatever and it was a
matter of grace the people who never
cheated it wasn't because they had the
struck strongest frontal cortexes it's
because you don't do that it was that
simple it wasn't a temptation and that's
much more of a model of it's not a realm
of just having to work so so hard to
feel for somebody else or not pocket
that thing even though nobody's looking
you just don't do that it's automatic
[Music]